au havre une femme est portée disparue
après une collision entre deux bateaux
les vents violents n'ont pas seulement
provoqué des dégâts en normandie le
point avec olivier sainte marie les
amarres de ce chimiquier n'ont pas
résisté aux vents violents
poussé par les rafales supérieures à 140
kilomètres heure il est allé percuter un
bateau avitailleurs dans le port du
havre ce matin une femme qui se trouvait
alors sur la passerelle du port est
tombé à l'eau elle est portée disparue
qui s'est passé à bord on nous a vite
fait parce que c'était un sauve qui peut
et la dame donc évoluer sur la paix sera
géré d'environ dans le calvados
on ne compte plus les routes coupées et
les maisons inondées les pompiers ont dû
intervenir plus de 200 fois au cours des
dernières 24 heures
par endroits l'eau a atteint 80
centimètres près de rouen ovale de
l'aller la scène s'est creusé un autre
lit de nombreux habitants se sont
réveillés les pieds dans l'eau et il
était à peu près trois heures et demie à
quatre heures du matin j'ai eu
l'impression qu'ils c'était une grosse
erreur c'est arrivé mais en fait quand
j'ai soulevé les rideaux c'était une
rivière qui envahissait la cour et quand
je suis venu pour fermer mon portail un
petit bonhomme comme avant vos prix se
faisait en bas léopards laup champs
inondés barrière arraché l'eau est
parfois monté d'un mètre en ille et
vilaine et en loire-atlantique l'état d'
alerte a été déclenchée dans plusieurs
communes situées en bordure de la
vilaine les dégâts sont également
importants dans les ardennes la nuit
dernière sapeur pompier a été grièvement
blessé alors qu'il travaillait à dégager
la route bloquée par les armes
malheureusement
un arbre était en désarment est encore
debout il y en a un qui l'aurait tomber
dessus c'est le cas de le dire
et ces arbres là c'est épicéa qui sont
il ya une trentaine d'années se déracine
avec le vent et puis le million en blanc
on n'entend rien du tout parce que ça
tombe sans bruit transporté à l'hôpital
de reims
le sapeur pompier se trouve dans un état
jugé très sérieux